yeah I'm yeah okay I'm a big fish in a
puddle so what all right they're not
doing anything you make a goddamn
kickass movie and you can take it all
over the planet earth now true I'm
making specific films and if you make a
specific film that's not everything for
everybody you're gonna turn some people
off I grandiose my way out of fear how
do you get that vision that's in your
head
how do you get it on the screen I worked
for got three years on a 16 millimeter
film that end up becoming nothing but
guitar picks
you also can't just lean when the when
the going gets tough not give up on your
vision do a heist film deliver the goods
is ìheís know but it's a high school
when you never see the heist now that
I've written the first pass on it what
do I think about it how can I make it
better
is there another element I can bring
into it you can't make a 14 year old
girl coming-of-age movie and I'll show
you without having a car chase break out
at some point he's an American filmmaker
and actor his films have garnered both
critical and commercial success he
receives a star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame for his contributions to the film
industry he's Quentin Tarantino and here
his top ten rules for success I got a UH
yeah I started working at this video
store was pretty much what you're
talking about around that time and and
it was great at first because I'd always
hated day jobs and stuff and so I got a
day job and it ended up being pretty
good but admittedly I was there for five
years at a certain point it was our
narcotic all right I didn't have to keep
pursuing my dreams because you know it's
not what I want to do but it's sort of
kind of close and if I didn't have an
artist soul burning in me I could have
made myself happy with that I could if i
if i didn't have an artist soul burning
to get out I could have you know walked
backwards a couple steps and just done
that and would have been a fulfilling
look to anybody else it would have been
a fulfilling life it would have been for
me because I wouldn't know and I would
have had something to say that I didn't
get a chance to say but it did put me to
sleep for a while and and I've always
just thought I mean what really got it
got everything kind of truly going from
you could point out a lot of different
things but the bottom line is the fact
that I realized that the even the group
people I hung around
with um they were all great great great
fellows and great gals but you know I
was easy for me to think that I was
doing a lot because I was doing more to
try to move myself forward than they
were but you know that's not yeah yeah
okay I'm a big fish in a puddle so what
all right they're not doing anything and
uh so yeah I'm doing more than them but
um I realize that actually I need to get
my ass out to Hollywood and meet other
people who are built like we were in my
category or or working a little higher
and and I should be the weakest link in
my chain that I have and that'll make me
be stronger or make me run faster I mean
like an analogy I've always used is
alright if you run the hundred yard dash
with a people that can't run as fast as
you yeah you'll win hands-down you know
that but if you run with people much
faster than you alright yeah you might
come in last every single time but your
time will be better because they're
making you run all the faster they're
making making you dig down just a little
bit more it doesn't matter that you and
your time is faster and that's what I
knew I had to do I had to get out of
Loserville and throw myself into a place
where like this is what they do for a
living you think it's still possible for
a upcoming filmmaker to go the route you
guys win still be successful that's good
question uh make Reservoir Dogs that's a
tough tough you know I'm not even being
is I'm not even being as smart as I was
a kick-ass movie alright you make a
goddamn kickass movie and you can take
it all over the planet Earth not America
enough Los Angeles not New York the
planet Earth and everyone will know it
there is a lot more competition than
there was when I was you know like
kicking around with El Mariachi so
you've got you know just a lot more to
do these days you got a lot more
competitions everybody's got a camera
now and everybody can edit and it's it's
just it's tough I don't know what the
state of independent filmmaking changes
that you know at the same time yeah
there's a lot more competition but also
those crappy movies aren't competent
thing is like dynamite oh yeah all that
[ __ ] is you know yeah there's a lot of
you a lot of people out there doing
stuff but if you know it's like waves on
the beach alright you make something
pick a piece of nitro that you throw in
an audience's lap ya know people notice
and people ask me from time to time do
you make a movie with an audience in
mind yeah and my answer is yes I do
alright but the audience I have in mind
isn't some faceless blobs that I'm
trying to second-guess hey it's me I
like a focus group
yeah it's me I'm the audience I'm the
guy that goes out and pays $7 or $8 in
New York in order to go and see a movie
all right I go soup I'm excited about
seeing a movie I see it on opening day
all right
I am the audience all right and I know
what I want to see you know and I was
betting and I was a little surprised at
how many there were I was betting that
there are other people like me out there
all right
now true I'm making specific films and
if you make a specific film that's not
everything for everybody you're gonna
turn some people off all right but
you're gonna turn some people on to when
you experience moments of self-doubt how
do you approach getting out of that dark
place good question
I grandiose my way out of fear if you
can imagine that it's a good way you
know I mean it's like literally it's
like okay I'm gonna do one of the
greatest car chases of all time and if I
don't I'm not as talented as I thought I
was and I will realize that there is a
ceiling to my talent right now I don't
think there is but if I don't do but if
it's not one of the greatest cartoons of
all time then I failed and I there is a
ceiling in my tongue I'm not as good as
I thought I was and I said that to
everybody and was I scared
yeah you're right I had trepidation
going all because it's mine to fail and
it's my anubian and it's failing in
front of the mirror too cuz I don't know
if I did it or not and I'll be like okay
yeah you are not as good as you thought
you were and that got me to Mount
Everest it's true every one point he
goes Robert can you imagine you and me
doing this car chase together how great
it's gonna be in a my game
you're on your own brother going out
there I got five kids
hundred-mile-an-hour bull you want to
live the vanishing point dream buddy
live it he did it all by himself and I'm
so proud you see movies and they and
they can have be full of vision and you
know you want your movies to be like
that but you know you see these other
movies that are don't have any vision
but i'm sure the director tried so
what's the difference between this guy
versus that guy how did he that was this
guy able to get this on the screen and
how is this guy not able to get this on
the screen I'm sure if I talk to that
guy he tell all these you know I'm sure
he wanted that who knows and I was
afraid of being that guy I would be that
guy and um
well Terry Gilliam definitely has a
vision no two three four ways about it
so we were at Sundance and it was like a
lunch going on the picnic tables there
and everyone else that bowed and it was
just me and him talking which was the
throw and don't look you know you have a
very specific vision in your movies and
it's right there on the screen how'd he
do that how do you get that vision
that's in your head how do you get it on
the screen and he said what Quentin you
have to understand as a director you
don't ask to do that your job is to hire
talented people who can do that you hire
a Senate Agra Fuhrer who can get the
kind of quality that you want you don't
have to be able to know how to take the
lights and move them around to create an
effect you hire a talented costume
designer who can give the colors that
you need and the flamboyance are not
that you want you hire a production
designer who can do that your job is
explaining your vision your job is
articulating to them what you want on
the screen and then all of a sudden the
whole mystical shamanistic thing that I
thought directing was just one and I
realized I could do that that it wasn't
this more
in like magic kit that I needed to know
the the right spell in order to conjure
like you I can describe what I want I
know what's in my head that's the
easiest part I'm good at describing to
get if you get the passion if you get
the passion to do it and you do it and
it doesn't like work out I worked for
got three years on a 16 millimeter film
that end up becoming nothing with guitar
picks and uh and I was very disappointed
when I realized it wasn't any good but
it was my film school alright and I
actually got away really cheap when it
was all over I knew how to make a movie
I want to show anybody that but I had
the experience I had a lot cheaper than
I would have gone if I'd gone to film
school if you're really gonna be an
artist with your own voice and you want
to do different things and try you know
not the standard thing then you know the
biggest balancing act you have to pull
isn't really even being a good filmmaker
we'll just say that you have that is
that balancing act between sticking to
your vision sticking to your voice but
not being some [ __ ] who could only
hear the sound of his own voice you know
and that's I mean it's all right there
that's it you got to be able to listen
to people you got to be able to hear
what they're saying but you also can't
just I mean when the when the going gets
tough not give up on your vision there's
a french director name is jean-pierre
melville who came out in the 50s and
basically started doing a whole series
and he was a total like entertainment
director he did a whole series of a
crime films always like sit in Paris or
Marseille or something they were
basically the Warner Brothers Bogart
Cagney films alright but completely set
to this like French Parisian rhythm and
they started like de la Alain Delon
program right and they're great and they
work very much in the same way that like
Sergio Leone's films do where they take
a genre that Wyck we know left right
forwards up and down and backwards
alright but they but they do it with a
whole different style and a holder
perspective and here they've basically
reinvented the genre they've created
something new that didn't exist before
now that's what I'm always kind of
trying to do with my genre films I don't
know if I'm succeeding or not but that's
the attempt to to take something you've
seen before I love it
I respect it and I'm gonna deliver the
goods I'm not just going to be some arty
guy going off
but I'm delivering the goods but I'm
also trying to you know reinvent it in a
way all right do something you know do
it in a much different way you've ever
seen before
lay in the case of Reservoir Dogs again
it's not trying to just be a clever boy
it's not just the clever ideas gotta
work dramatically all right but like you
know do a heist film deliver the goods
is ice no but it's a high school when
you never see the heist
that's just my goofy way of doing it hey
oh is it like if I was gonna do like you
a hunchback movie they got to get like
you have an operation at the beginning
like I usually that by the other day I
started writing like say around you know
10:00 10:30 11:00 something like that
and then I write till about uh you know
five six or seven something like that
but around around that time around five
or six I'm going to stop for the day and
what I do is I stop for the day and then
after a little bit of time of unwinding
I go into my pool and I keep him all
nice and warm there and everything and
so I just kind of hang out in the pool
and if I'm not done with something
nothing okay um what do I want to do
what how how do I want to go further
with this now that I've written the
first pass on it what do I think about
it how can I make it better
is there another element I can bring
into it did I do add too much to a line
whatever I'm just looking at it
critically and maybe I come up with some
neat ideas and then I get out of the
pool and I make notes on those neat
ideas that I came up with like thinking
meditating about it it actually is
meditating and then that's my work
tomorrow when I get up all right
or if I finished a scene okay boom well
that's done now that part of the story
is done now I go in the pool and go okay
what happens next what's the next thing
and then I usually come up with a pretty
good idea and then I make my notes and
that's the next day's work and that was
never really the way I did it and that
has become exclusively the way I did
inglorious basterds in Django and
and it it truly brings a lot of joy to
my life it's a really really lovely
lovely way to work that makes me feel
really happy the American car chases
that we grew up loving in the 70s like
the driver bullet or French Connection
you know they were location-based that
was part of it the fact that the chasing
is happening in downtown LA at night you
know the word turns into a ghost town in
the driver or even like colors alright
the fact that it's through watch that's
a that's a deal
that's a thing alright um but then once
the Australians got involved in that
they revolutionized car chases and I'm
not just talking about Mad Max I mean
you can't make a 14 year old girl
coming-of-age movie and I'll show you
without having a car chase breakout at
some point but the thing they did that
was so great was feel location Orion is
the outback all right everything looks
like this same all right so uh so hey
you know all of a sudden they didn't
have drive-by shots everything you were
in the chase you were with the cars
constantly every second it was like
[ __ ] to put a car off the side of the
road narrow narrow you know they were
with them and still I wanted to actually
do that I wanted to you know do the
Australian style and bringing it but
then there's even one more difference
and that is who's chasing who right all
right
most of the time it's the is the
protagonist is being chased by a bunch
of cops like in Blues Brothers or
something like that you're being chased
by somebody but the most exciting chases
the ones that you're you're on the edge
you see I got up get up get up get up
get up
alright is when the protagonist is
chasing the person and you want that
person to get caught
that's French Connection that's what
makes French connections because you
want pop idol to get that bastard all
right and those were always more
emotionally connected when you were
following the hero why both am i I have
the girls being chase I had the girls
chasing so I tried to hit all those
emotional basis
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because the Muro
brothers asked me to so there's a
favorite entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next leave it in the comments
below I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of quiting
Tarantino's top ten rules at the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
and I'll join the discussion and one
last thing my personal goal with this
channel is to get it to 1 million
subscribers so what do you think of the
help share it tweeted comment give it to
some friends out of the playlist I'd
really really really appreciate it thank
you guys so much
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
well you know I have to say you know all
that criticism that came out I didn't
have being kind of a good thing because
one of the things that I wanted to do is
I wanted to actually start a
conversation about slavery about
America's role in it and to actually
take an audience member from the 21st
century and stick them in the antebellum
South and see what it would in heaven
have a sense of what America was like
back then
and so even the people that have been
created have criticized the movie and
some a lot of people don't like it and I
connect and understand that a lot of
people do like it and they've been kind
of going back and forth and that back
and forth is really what I really wanted
for the end of the day of this movie and
I hope that I Archie even continues for
the next few years it truly is a
situation where we just 70 we were yeah
exactly we would Trulia because you know
he was my audience and I was his
audience and everything and he was like
the perfect sounding board so we really
would like you know inspire each other
to go further to like it oh oh this is
all Brock's gonna love this all right
I'd read him this and and then he even
come up with like oh man that's gonna be
so cool the greatest gunfight never
heard I remember that silencer gunfight
you had at one point and actually was
the Columbia is the Sony lot so like
Versailles that Cuban place is right
across the street so we'd like me we wit
web spin all day and then go at
Versailles and I II didn't eat and just
talked about how we were gonna take over
Hollywood a reporter or something will
say we wouldn't do a big in-depth story
on Quentin we want to just spend some
time with him and just you know they
have him do what he does during his day
what I do during my day is I go out to
restaurants and I go to movies yeah
that's what I do you know and I hang out
with my friends and stuff uh uh you know
I'm not into sports I don't like sports
anything with the ball no good alright
uh I'm not into sports I'm not into cars
or anything like I mean I'm into driving
a car but I'm not into like you know I'm
not IND I don't collect cars and make
model cars or anything like that I'm in
the movie stuff and horror stuff and and
like I said just hanging out with my
friends and watching TV and
and you know messing around and now I'm
into travel I like traveling I love
traveling I love being here in London
that's great I love going different
places and stuff but that's it you know
that's that's kind of what I like to do
the best thing is now that I'm making a
living in the industry I have a little
bit money is that you have to see before
when I didn't have any money at all
all I spent my money on was movie stuff
anyway but buying videos buying records
you know buying movie poster big movie
poster collection buying all that you
remember Bill you buying all that crap
all right when I didn't have any money
to spend I spend my rent money on that
stuff see now I got more money to spend
on it and it's tax-deductible because
it's all in the industry so I get it all
I have much more money to spend I can
buy damn near anything I want all right
and it's all written off at the end of
the year I mean so it's like what a life
this is great